تلقت سيده بريطانيه في التاسعه وستين من
العمر خلايا دم حمراء زرعت في مختبر في
اول تجربه سريريه من نوعها في العالم في
هذا المجال في خطوه يتوقع ان تحدث ثوره في
العلاج ادي الدراسه التي اطلق عليها اسم
الترميم تمهد الطريقه امام امدادات خلايا
الدم الحمراء للمرضى المصابين بخلل في
الدم كالخلايا المنجليه وذوي الانواع
النادره من الفصائل الدم الذين يصعب ايجاد
متبرعين لهم وتتم تجربه بالتعاون مع خدمه
الصحه الوطنيه في بريطانيا وجامعه
كيمبريتش وقال البروفيسور صدرك جفرت
المتخصص في الطب نقل الدم بجامعه كيمبريدج
والمشارك في التجربه ان التجربه السريريه
رائده لانها المره الاولى التي تزرع فيها
خلايا حمراء في المختبر بطريقه يمكن
للعلماء من خلالها مقارنه سلوكها بعد نقل
الدم مقابل الخلايا الحمراء
المعتاده التي يتم التبرع بها
انا من بوسطن البروفيسور الساده امراض
السرطان والمناعه في جامعه
هارفرد
هذه الخلايا زرعت في المختبر يعني من اين
جاءت كيف زرعت
مساء الخير اول شيء لالكم للمشاهدين
الطريقه اللي صارت هذه الدراسه بالزيت انه
اول مره الخلايا يلي اخذتها المراه
طبيعيه يعني اخذت انفيوجن من شخص معين
واعطيه وزرعوا
نفس الخلايا من نفس الشخص
وبعد رجع
خلايا جزائيه وبعد ما
كبرونية الجزعيه اعطيه ولا نفس اعطيه ولا
للمراه بالذات وراقبوا شو تفاعل المراه
دائما بنعملها بالطريقه الطبيعيه بناخذ دم
من شخص نعطيه لشخص الثاني والتجربه
الثانيه اللي هي الخياليه يلي رمموها او
كبروها بالمختبر والنتيجه كانت ميه بالميه
متطابقه
يعني ما اهميه هذا او هذه التجربه
السريريه ان كان في كلتا الحالتين نحتاج
لدونر لمن يعطي اما الدم اما الخلايا
الجذعيه
لا مش لانه عم نعمل هون تجربه صيدليه
مجبورين المجهورين ناخذ الخلايا من نفس
الشخص بس نقدر للمقارنه بس اكيد بالمستقبل
اذا هيدي التجربه صارت مزبوطه بالمستقبل
ما راح منا بحاجه لانسان يعطينا يعطينا
الدم ناخد دم ناخذ خليه سمسا من حي الله
شخص ما بنكبرهم بالمختبر وبنعمل الخلايا
اللي الخليه الحمراء اللي نحن بدنا اياها
كل مره نحتاج لشخص متبرع
في كل مره اول مره لا لا مش مضبوط اول مره
بس يعني اول ما ناخذ الدم ناخذ من شخص
تنقدر نكبره من محله خلص بنصير نكبرهم
بالمختبر وفي طرق معينه ممكن نجلدهم ممكن
نحطهم
كتير حرارتها تنقدر نخلي الخلايا
عايشه ونعطيها لاشخاص ثاني او كمان دائما
المختبر بيكون مكبره وبنعمل بالمختبر
تطابق عده انواع الدم عده فئات دم ومنقدر
نعطيه نساعدها للاشخاص يعني ما ابدا مش
بحاجه اسهل وايسر من مجرد نقل الدم اللي
هو عمليه بسيطه يعني يعرفها كل الناس
ويستطيع ان يفعلها اي مختبر واي مشفى في
العالم
هون الاهميه هون مش الاهميه عند بكل
الحالات في حالات معينه مثل
فصيله دم نادره مثل
هذه الفصيله الدم كتير نادره يعني بس واحد
بالميه من عندهم هايدي الفصيله بقى بهاي
هون بهاي الطريقه كتير مهمه لانه بنقدر
نعطي لهذه الاشخاص
نامن لهم دم بحاجه لذوق ما نقدر نبرم لميت
شخص لنقدر نامن الدم لشخص واحد
كمان في
امراض بالدم مثل داء الكريات المنزليه
بهذه الحالات كتير صعب بنقدر نامن فئات
الدم وفي كمان ممكن غير غير غير مرض يكون
صعب تامين الدم لهذا الشخص بالذات هون
بيصير كتير اهميه هذه الدراسه بعدين انت
انه ممكن هل هنالك مواصفات للمتبرع بهذه
الخلايا يعني هل يكون ينبغي ان تكون له
مواصفات محدده ام يمكن لاي شخص ان ناخذ
منه خلايا جذعيه ثم يتم زراعتها في
المختبر وهل الشخص المصاب نفسه يمكن اخذ
خلايا جذعيه منه هو التعامل معها بحيث
تكون خلايا حمراء وخاليه من العيوب التي
يعني يعاني منها في دمه
اكيد اول شيء من المهم انه الشخص اللي بده
يعطي الخلايا الجزعيه من الاساس بده يكون
شخص ما عنده اي مرض متل اللي بيعطي دم
بهذا الفتره يعني دايما نطلع اذا شخص معه
سرطان ما بيقدر يعطي الدم اذا شخص عنده
امراض مزمنه ما بيقدر ما بيقدروا بس بس
هون بحب شدد انه ما بدنا بقى يعني الخلايا
خلايا الجزعيه ممكن تجيب من حياه لمحل
ونكمبرها بالمختبر ومنخليها بالمختبر
لسنين طويله يعني يعني ما بدنا بقى شخص
يعطي يعطي الخلايا الجزعيه من الاول انه
عنا خلايا جزائيه كثيره بس بحب دراسه
مجبورين نعملها بهذه المقارنه لنقدر ناكد
انه المرحلتين او الطريقتين اللي اتامل
الدم لهذه المراه كانت طبيعيه وعاطت نتيجه
مئه بالمئه متطابقه
يعني هي تجربه سريريه
هذه التجربه تمت متى يمكن تعميم هذه
التجربه ما هي المراحل التي يجب ان تمر
بها لكي تصبح مستخدمه من قبل الاطباء او
معتمده اكيد دائما
بكل التجارب السريريه عند مرحله اولى
مرحله ثانيه يعني مرحله اولى نعملها على
اشرف فئه اشخاص معينه كثير رقم بكون قصير
يعني من عشر اشخاص ممكن تكون
منراجع كل النتائج اللي معنا اذا كل
النتائج متطابقه وما في مشاكل ننقل
للمرحله الثانيه اللي بتكون على
الاف الاشخاص ومش الاف يعني بهذه الحاله
هون يمكن الف شخص ممكن يكون رفيق اكيد بكل
بلد عندك
ممكن هو يقرر شو لازم شو لازم يكون
الحالات بس اكيد يعني بعدنا باول مرحله بس
هيدا عن جد مثل ما قالوها هيدي هيدي هيدا
الشي علمي كتير كتير هائل يعني اللي صار
معنا بهذه السنه يعني بكثير ممكن يقدم
العلم والطب لمرحله قدام متقدمه يعني
هل هو قابل
للتعامل معه في اي بيئه علميه او اي بيئه
طبيه يحتاج الى بنيه اساسيه صحيه محدده
لانه احنا نتحدث عن خلايا جذعيه
لا هلا بكل مختبر عندك عندك محلات بدها
تكون معقمه بطريقه معينه تنقدر نكبر
الخلايا دائما يعني بس حيا الله مختلفه
يمكن ان تكون مثل هذه التقنيه موجوده يمكن
ان تعمل
اكيد كتير كتير سهل أكيد وهذا مهم سؤالك
لانه دائما بحب شدد انه بالعالم الثالث
مثلا بالمناطق العربيه عنا كمان ممكن ممكن
ينصنع هذا الشيء اكيد ممكن ينعمل والتكلفه
ما بتكون كتير عاليه مثل مثل يعني ممكن
اكيد ممكن يصير بس اكيد بدك حدا ياخذ هذا
الموضوع على
عتقه ويقدر
يعمل هذه الاشياء عنه نشكرك شكرا جزيلا
الدكتور باخ طنوس استاذه امراض السرطان
والمناعه في جامعه هارفرد ضيفنا من بوست